is there a falsifiable element to string
theory is there any experiment or
combination of experiments that would
cause you Michio to reconsider your
claim of the god equation ultimately be
found five possible ways to test String
Theory String Theory does not stop at
the Institute of creation String Theory
goes before the incident of creation
there's a Multiverse of universes out
there and so we can talk about pre-big
Bank physics how do we do that we look
for post Big Bang radiation and then run
the videotape backwards using string
theory equations to get radiation
profile from before the creation of the
universe itself
[Music]